I told you yesterday on the show that
the Tucker Carlson hour on Fox News lost
about half of its audience
um in the week after Tucker Carlson's
firing not hugely surprising people are
tuning in for Tucker right I mean when I
go on vacation we lose about 50 of our
audience as well
um the funny thing is that every guest
host that they seem to try over there
seems to just go worse and worse and
worse this one is really funny yesterday
the latest attempt at Tucker's
replacement is a guy named Lawrence
Jones who's worked at Fox News for some
period of time
he arguably did the worst job of anybody
so far he interviewed ASA Hutchinson ASA
Hutchinson is a republican candidate
he's a former Republican governor
Republican candidate for president for
the Republican nomination his campaign
is totally Dead on Arrival but they
interviewed him anyway fine the
interview lasted eight and a half
minutes the interviewer Lawrence Jones
spoke about half of that time more than
four of the eight and a half minutes
Lawrence Jones was speaking often
yelling over ASA Hutchinson and he tried
the wire you running sort of gotcha and
when they saw I mean listen I think the
policies are stupid and they're bad
policies but ASA Hutchinson is naming
the things he did as Governor which
Republicans generally do like and Jones
tries to short-circuit it by saying
every Republican does that stuff and
it's sort of like well what do you want
me to say I did the things Republicans
like listen to this humiliating attempt
at an interview
this is fair that that is spin
um the Republicans have said what their
position is I understand that you for
free speech and all these other issues
and like I said respectfully sir I
understand that you're for economic
freedom and all that those are the
typical Republican positions and that
would work back in 2008 or even 2006 but
there's a different Republican party now
and when I ask you the question why are
you running it seems like you're opposed
to all of the things that the modern day
Republican party stands for what do you
say to the
well I disagree with that I lowered
taxes in Arkansas that's real again
Republicans
you've got to listen to me as well
you've got to listen as well we've
balanced the budget that's what
Republicans do we lead in this country
yeah but did you make fun of a disabled
reporter do you pretend do do you
pretend weightlift to attack trans
people during your rallies that's what
the party wants now conservative
principles and whenever you're looking
at our values I stand second to none in
terms of fighting for pro-life values
and conservative values look at my
record Lawrence Governor I just went
through your record here and as I said
and I gave you credit for the normal
Republican positions you're right in
line but this is a new Republican party
thank you so much for your time sir
all right not exactly a conversation I
believe that the search continues for a
replacement for Tucker Carlson on Fox
News if you're curious you can check out
that that entire interview the good news
for Lawrence Jones is Almost no one is
watching fox in that time slot anymore
so not that many people saw him
humiliate himself it's hard to determine
who's less ready for prime time uh
Lawrence Jones or or Ron DeSantis and
what he did is he wanted to impress I
guess his bosses
so he came out ready to fight because
fight is good but when you just talk
over your guest and you speak for half
the interview when you're supposed to be
hearing the ideas of the other person it
just doesn't really work very well and I
expect we'll see what the numbers look
like by the end of this week I expect
that this week's Tucker ratings The
formerly Tucker ratings will be even
worse than last week so Fox News
certainly has some problems on its hands
I'm not too worried about helping them
solve those problems and if you're
curious what this interview looked like
we'll have the clip on our Instagram
which you can find by searching
Instagram for David Pacman show we're
going to take a quick break
so much more to discuss with you today
one of our sponsors is short form short
form makes the world's best guides to
non-fiction books and not only does
short form Summarize each non-fiction
book itself into key points that you can
cover in just a few minutes they have
all sorts of interactive exercises to
help you apply the ideas to what you've
read to retain more the guide to each
book also includes intellectual insights
comparing and contrasting the book to
other prominent books about the same
topic so that you can contextualize the
book and understand the controversies
and the disagreements they also have
books across every non-fiction genre
from economics and politics to science
and health I was recently checking out
James clear's Atomic habits on short
form of course they have the guide but
they also have highlights they also
include other similar books about habits
and developing a routine with
differences and similarities super super
useful and a lot more than just a
summary of the book there are new guides
and articles released every week and
short form is giving my audience a free
trial plus 25 off a subscription which
is a fifty dollar value so for the price
of a book per month you get access to
thousands go to shortform.com Pacman the
link is down below